HENRY NEWTON-DUNN: Cars
are integral to the way
people live their lives today.
We use cars for taking
our kids to school.
We use our cars for
commuting to work.
But when we look at
cars today, they're
fundamentally
disconnected vehicles.
PATRICK BRADY: People don't
want to check their phones
at the door when they
get behind the wheel.
So we partnered with auto
manufacturers and technology
partners to figure
out the best way
to bring Android into the car.
Today we're announcing
Android Auto,
which extends the Android
platform into the car.
Android Auto combines
the best of both worlds.
You get the connected apps and
services on your smartphone
with the physical
controls that were
optimized for
driving in your car.
We had to go back
to the drawing board
and really take
an experience that
was designed for a
smartphone, and break it down
to its bare essentials.
HENRY NEWTON-DUNN: We focused
it down to the features
that the user really needs
within the driving space.
We've made Google Maps really
easy to use for the car.
We've got nice, easy-to-access
touch targets and a simplified
interface.
The voice technology that
we're using within the car
is super conversational.
PATRICK BRADY: Your
hands are on the wheel.
Your eyes are on the road.
MALE SPEAKER: Set a reminder
to get gas on the way
back to work.
Pick up my dry cleaning.
Remind me to get
tickets on the way home.
PATRICK BRADY: Google brings
you just the right information
at just the right time.
So when you set reminders
while you're driving,
your phone will
remind you later on,
even if you're outside the car.
Android developers will soon
be able to create entirely
new experiences for the car.
HENRY NEWTON-DUNN: We're really
excited about this opportunity.
Because for us, this is really
very much at the beginning.
And we're really going to
go a long journey with this.